no big challenge has ever been solved
and no lasting improvement has
ever been achieved unless people dare
to try something different dare to
think different be fearless
be the last people to accept things as
they are
and the first people to stand up and
change them for the better
back over your shoulder fondly and say
goodbye to act one of your life
and then quickly look forward act two
begins today
it's your turn to reach out and take the
baton
you enter the world at a time of great
challenge
our country is deeply divided and too
many americans refuse to hear
any opinion that differs from their own
our planet is warming with devastating
consequences
and there's some that even deny it's
even happening
our schools and communities suffer from
deep inequality we fail to guarantee
every student the right to a good
education
and yet we are not powerless
in the face of these problems you
are not powerless to fix them
no generation has ever had more power
than yours
and no generation has a chance
to change things faster than yours can
the pace at which progress is possible
has accelerated dramatically
aided by technology every individual has
the tools potential and reach to build a
better world
that makes this the best time
in history to be alive whatever you
choose to do with your life
wherever your passion takes you
i urge you to take the power you have
been given
and use it for good aspire to
leave this world better than you found
it
i didn't always see life as clearly as i
do
today but i've learned the greatest
challenge of life
is knowing when to break with
conventional wisdom
don't just accept the world you inherit
today
don't just accept the status quo
no big challenge has ever been solved
and no lasting improvement has ever been
achieved
unless people dare to try something
different
dare to think different
i was lucky to learn from someone who
believed this deeply
someone who knew that changing the world
starts with following a vision
not a path he was my friend
and mentor steve jobs
vision was the great ideas comes from a
restless refusal to accept things as
they are
and those principles still guide us at
apple today
in every way at every turn the question
we ask ourselves
is not what can we do
but what should we do
because steve taught us that's how
change happens
and from him i learned to never be
content
with the way that things are
i believe this mindset comes naturally
to young people
and you should never let go of this
restlessness 50 years ago today
may 13 1968
robert kennedy was campaigning in
nebraska
and spoke to a group of students who
were wrestling with that same question
kennedy gave the students a call to
action
when you look across this country and
when you see people's lives held back by
discrimination in poverty
when you see injustice and inequality
he said you should be the last people
to accept things as they are
let kennedy's words echo here today
you should be the last people
to accept it whatever path you've chosen
be it medicine or business engineering
of the humanities whatever
drives your passion be the last
to accept the notion that the world you
inherit cannot be improved
be the last to accept the excuse that
says that's just how things are done
here
you should be the last people to accept
it
and you should be the first to change it
you are uniquely qualified
and therefore uniquely responsible to
build
a better way forward
[Music]
that won't be easy it will require
great courage but that courage will not
only help you live your life to the
fullest
it will empower you to transform the
lives of others
last month i was in birmingham to mark
the 50th anniversary of dr
king's assassination and i had the
incredible privilege of spending time
with women and men who marched and
worked alongside him
many of them were younger at the time
than you are now
they told me when they defied their
parents
and joined the sit-ins and the boycotts
when they faced the police dogs and the
fire hoses
they were risking everything they had
becoming foot soldiers for justice
without a second
thought because they knew that change
had to come
because they believed so deeply in the
cause of justice
because they knew even all the adversity
that they had faced
they had the chance to build something
better for the next generation
we can all learn from their example
if you hope to change the world you must
find your fearlessness
fearlessness means taking the first step
even if you don't know where it will
take you
it means being driven by a higher
purpose
rather than by applause
it means knowing that you reveal your
character
when you stand apart more than when you
stand with the crowd
if you step up without fear of failure
if you talk and listen to each other
without fear of rejection
if you act with decency and kindness
even when no one is looking even if it
seems small
or inconsequential trust me
the rest will fall into place
more importantly you'll be able to
tackle the big things when they come
your way
it's in those truly trying moments
that the fearless inspire us
in 1964 martin luther king jr
gave a speech at page auditorium to an
overflow crowd
dr king warned them that someday
we would all have to atone not only for
the words and actions of the bad people
but for the appalling silence and
indifference of the good people who sit
around and say
wait on time the time
is always right to do right
for you that time is now
[Music]
it will always be now it's time to add
your brick
to the path of progress it's time for
all of us to move forward and it's time
for you
to lead the way